this is one of the nice things about
talking about ufos
is it expands the overton window it
expands our understanding of what
possibly could be life
it gets us to think it gets the
scientific community to think when we go
to mars
we go to these different moons that
possibly have life
you know we're not looking at uh legged
organisms we're looking at some kind of
complexity
that uh
arises in resistance to the natural
world
and um
there's a lot of interesting
resistance to the natural world yeah so
somehow
there's a rebellious process complex
system going on here
and i don't know you know the many ways
it could take form and there's a sense
you know for aliens that
as the technology develops they take
form more and more
in as information
as something that can influence the
space of
of ideas of the
processing of data itself so i just uh
this idea of embodiment that we humans
so admire
physically visible perceivable
embodiment
may be a very
uh inefficient thing
right if you think just about
you know your area ai you know we're
we're
trying to make smaller and smaller and
smaller
uh circuitry
that is uh
basically
closer and closer to the physics of how
the universe operates
right right down at the level of i mean
quantum computers are basically write
down about quantum information storage
so
fast forward ten thousand a hundred
thousand years
maybe somebody found a way to embody ai
directly into the physics of the
universe
right
and it doesn't require physical
manifestation
it just it just sits in space-time it's
just a locally ordered space we're just
locally ordered space time
right
you know i mean people
but maybe they just they found a way to
embody it there
they probably have to get really good at
not you know trampling on the ants
the the better your technology gets the
easier it is to accidentally like oops
just destroy these simpleton biological
systems
we constantly think about whatever these
things might be we think that they are
some sort of a unified
force
well maybe they're not unified
maybe they are as disparate
as you and i are
and maybe what keeps them
from stomping all over the ants is each
other
right that they are in a self tension
to
prevent
one or more of them from running amok
oh yeah i mean that's kind of the
anarchy of nations that we have on earth
so there's there's always
there's always going to be this um
there's a hierarchy this hierarchy
that's formed of greater and greater
intelligences right and they're all
probably also wondering
wait what's bigger than me exactly
that's what i always wonder is that
maybe that they're what keeps them in
line
is something that is beyond them like
what created the universe i mean that
and that's probably a question that
bothers them too
you